what a year huh
what a year
dude if you had a bag full of years
and you picked this one out of the bag
just say they blindfolded everybody
and then you reach in the bag and
everybody gets a year
dude this would be this would be a
freaking wild one to draw
what a year the shake-up baby
the shake-up
mother nature just unleashed that um
you know she unleashed that dirty sauce
out into the air
and people getting it people getting
lunged out
on mother nature she threw that dirty
dust out into the air
people getting lunged out people on you
know
just shook people shocked people can't
you know
people getting gripped out by the
disease man
a damn guy in um in tennessee blew up a
freaking uh an rv
a good rv the guy parked it out in front
of a hooters and damn blew it up
and twin peaks is better anyway and i
know and you know it
and i'm not trying to tell i'm not
trying to preach at you but i'm just
saying damn twin peaks is better
all the good you know tits
all those good you know them front bags
baby you feel me
all them freaking the milky headlamps
they've all
migrated long ago over to um
twin peaks i mean really the only people
still working at hooters is orange
[ __ ]
let's be honest and no offense um
el perros
but that's the facts that's the only
people
still working at hooters
are mostly really teachers assistants
who are afraid to do only fans and
orange [ __ ] that's facts man
dude that is facts baby
it's the new year it's the new year we
did it 2021
we're in the future baby this is the
future man this is
this is what elon musk puts on his salad
baby
this is the future can you even imagine
that we are this is the future
we are every actually every moment
you're doing the future
when you start a word where you
end is in the future man that's crazy
um we're here this is it 2021 has been a
wild one
um i don't even know if i have any music
do we have any
you know what there's something on here
hold on
[Music]
oh yeah it's that gentle
this that euthanasia soundtrack
yeah that's when your doctor tells you
you shouldn't have any more sugar and
you just
lay in bed and have a damn brownie
or a snickerdoodle man
this is megan wofford ald langston
this is that into somebody's life
they're you know down the street some
man down the street he's in
his life is ending and he finally has a
you know can admit that he molested
somebody or did something you know
you know through a frisbee when somebody
been down to pick it up touched it right
you know did something wild
but he denies it just goes to heaven or
hell
[Music]
you can hear the frisbee
oh yeah
[Music]
there you go right there that is oh
lying sign all
lang syne it sound you know that's the
new year's anthem people
some people don't know what it's called
and it's called all old
old lying sign
and i had a waiter like that once had a
mellow mushroom
he would he just he made like extra
sounds like when he was talking
you know like out of each
order like what
you guys get a little right there hey
you yeah
you need your appetizer hey
he like made his own background noise
you know
it was like oh we're gonna see you
tonight he's like what dude why are you
we all of you guys who um we have a new
uh
you know we oh oh you chicken best go
all right
like what dude just tell you know if you
hate just tell me what you have
good to see you guys and uh and not even
see you really
just see with my heart and and with my
imagination but
um i just can't believe we that we're
making it this far
and the world it is getting unique out
there
you know i mean some fella damn blew up
a rv a decent camper
okay that thing slept six honey
but in the end it slept one you feel me
but
some man kill bossed that [ __ ] over
there
downtown in the central east out there
in tennessee
and he was lonesome it said you know
there was a little
here and there he said something they
you know he
thought about lizard people or something
but you know he was probably listening
to a
tinfoil hat i have no idea but he you
know the guy
i mean it was a lonely dude that blew
himself up
and i'm not shocked
first of all it's hard to park down
there let's be honest downtown parking
who has not wanted to sometimes
when i'm downtown and i can't i'm
looking for parking i literally wish
that my glove box
was a little oven and i just want to put
my head on there
in there and go full blast honey
i want to set that [ __ ] on nine and
grill my thoughts because i'm damn angry
that's why
god people been angry this year man this
year got everybody
who knows who know look virtual reality
you'll see a lot of children nowadays
you run you you drive down the street
and
there's a kid in the yard you'll just
see him hiding behind
hiding behind nothing he'll just kind of
be crouching like he's and he's playing
hide and go seek in his head with
virtual you know with somebody in damn
guantanamo bay or russia or somewhere
you know michigan and it's
you know the virtual reality who knows
what it's going to be
there's a new thing where people
are just have jobs in virtual reality
so now is unbelievable the highlight is
you have a lazy child
with a thing on with the vr on do like
flipping burgers
or you know working at a shake shack
or do you know making kleenexes working
at a kleenex factory
it's just on so now you can't even get
your kid to work but he'll
put on goggles and go
[ __ ] work at a job that's not even
real
oh my god
and pardon me look i'm no scientist man
if you
logged on here ended up here somehow
through some
you know chat room or portal
and you think that i am a science man
then you you are a real stray animal
because
that's not that's not factual i'm not
you know i don't know anything about
science and
um and i'm honestly i'm probably
part-time believer in science
so depending when depends on kind of
when you catch me and how i'm feeling
that day but
um oh man what was i talking about
i don't even know i literally do not
even know
i know that today's episode is brought
to you by magic mind
i do know that and we're very grateful
for them for coming on this
uh this year this past year
um they are the antithesis
of uh of procrastination
you're tired of procrastinating change
the way you do things
you know nothing changes if nothing
changes i heard that
and magic mind will change things
it is basically the organic version of
coffee
and you can check it out at magicmind.co
and use promo code theo for 10 off to
try it out
i got a little vial of it right here
that hitter
and um i mean it really puts you into a
flow state you know a lot of people try
to achieve flow state and to really
assist yourself that helps
yeah we're in the future i mean it's
just like it i want sometimes i start to
think what if
the um disease
you know bro first of all think of this
when corporate came out you know
whatever they called it corvid 19.
first of all a lot of people thought it
was a wide receiver okay for texas tech
or somebody
people like damn corbin 19. man this
[ __ ] is [ __ ] people up
people like why damn how many touchdowns
did he have you know
but then it hit remember in the
beginning they put everybody on
ventilators and it
killed thousands of people for no reason
they just plug people up to these things
and we're just reverse vacuuming out
people
we are just animals man we don't know
what's going on
but i start to wonder what if because i
don't know how it's going to just
suddenly it's going to just disappear
you know a lot of people are susceptible
or
questionable about the vaccine
and i don't blame them dude this vaccine
seems like something somebody made at
the last
minute to get a c and i only say that
because
i'm that guy i'm the dude
who was writing who was writing a book
report on the bus
you know i'm the dude who would find the
one asian not even asian semi-asian kid
and like i beg him to give me the
answers and he didn't even go to our
school
he worked near the school
he he you know and he still knew the
answers which was crazy
you know i'm just curious i mean i'm
just you know i'm hopeful that we get
into
that this year brings some answers i
mean i just i start to wonder what
virtual reality are
kids going to like
is everybody's gonna move back in with
their parents and do fake jot like do
you know
some kids just laying in his room all
day with his mouth open
working 60 hours at a at a uh
you know at a calendar factory
you know just gluing sundays onto a you
know one of a sheet of paper
you know i just don't know
i just start to wonder like
and then the kid gets off of the thing
and he just feels like he's been at work
all day but he hasn't
and then what if our world like we don't
start to be outside and do stuff anymore
and we actually start to be in this
virtual reality world
so then everybody starts to get virtual
reality to go you even have to have it
to go to anything
ever we're all just laying on our floors
with our mouths open
and just going to work in our heads or
doing this or doing that
you know we're at a party but where
nobody's even there we're all just
and look virtual reality is powerful
it's powerful man i i went to the fox
labs
um and it's not like animal sex or
anything like that it's like uh
what it's not like endangered species
sex i mean it's like um
the network like fox network fox studios
in los angeles and
they took me in the virtual reality room
one time
and they showed me some of the stuff
they had bro they had a game
where i could see little gnomes i was in
a
like in a woods you know
and you could walk up to a tree and open
little doors and they had like little a
little gnomes in there would look up at
you
they're in there you know bro you know
brushing teeth putting on a coat
doing deodorant you know one of them's
in there sneaking a little head of
pudding before bed the little one you
know
and now that you open the little doors
and peek in their tree home and they all
look up at you like they're kind of
spooked
and then you you close it and you're
back out in the woods and those little
bridges going from trees to trees in the
woods and little gnomes would run across
them
and a little gnome hand you a little uh
he'll trade you something a little peach
you know for something little shoe
polish you know like prison
you know he'll trade you [ __ ] you
know he'll trade you maybe a little bit
of
light oral you know not oral sex just
you know
just not like a kiss but just at least
whistle in my mouth or something a lot
touch myself
kind of [ __ ] but um
anyway man i don't know what i'm getting
at i'm just i'm just starting to wonder
what are the next
futures going to look like
because for me i think i kind of
evaluate the future come january 1.
and that's when i start to look at the
past
and um and so that's what i'm starting
to wonder as i see
virtual reality
you know when i was young if you want to
do virtual reality you had to do a
little bit of acid
hit your low lsd you know
you know you take a little couple grams
of uh
you know mushrooms bruh
i remember doing mushrooms at school
once and i remember i had on a green
shirt and i thought it was a snake
and so half the day i spent half the day
hiding from my left arm
and uh and that's hard to do bro
that is i mean that's the real rodeo
right there
you know i know a lot of these guys in
the pbr circuit and stuff they get out
there and they do
you know eight seconds on fiasco that
famous bull but i'd love to see an mf or
get out there
on about 60 grams of psilocybin
and [ __ ] hide from his left arm
that snake um
what else i want to think oh i want to
let everybody know january 15th
um we are doing a live
show it is myself and uh chelsea lynn
trailer trash tammy and it's gonna be
fun man she's so creative and just
she she just has so much joy in her
you know i mean damn if you you know you
shot a missile ladder you just
joy would blow up all over everybody
so you'd see somebody just damn slip in
a puddle of j-o-y
but um i'm so excited about that i
really am and it's made me feel creative
again thinking about that and
we've shot some sketches and we're gonna
have some live performers
um it's gonna be something and we're
trying to pull it all off live so
you can get tickets now uh the link will
be
uh at the top here in the information
and and you'll also be able to watch it
for about 10 days after that
on the link and uh
and it's going to be great we're really
putting a lot of effort into it so i'm
excited about that
i'm excited to give everybody like a
cool product and
um and just to do something fun with her
and to
go outside of my comfort zone
you know and last year i really got in
my comfort zone and i just think i got
scared and
um a lot of times
you know because you know i've had a
couple of years where my career gotten
bigger and
it and i don't know what happened this
past year
i think i just got kind of spooked maybe
i don't know stress lost
everything you know me jesus christ man
i'm a handsome and gretel bro
you know what i'm saying i don't know
what the [ __ ] going on man
but i'm always missing in the woods
brother
um but yeah you'll be able to grab a
ticket to that and thank you so much for
the support in advance
and i'm i'm excited to do something with
uh just really a special female talent i
feel like
and a special talent anyway no matter if
she has
you know that
that vagina or not daddy gang um
and then some of this episode is just
going to be uh flashbacks from the year
and producer nick and um our producer
sean
uh in the central east they're going to
put together some clips from the year
that they really enjoyed
um and what else
you know i went home i saw my family man
everybody got gold chains i got from the
uh
i rolled up at the k jewelers and this
fella big anthony in there
little thick fella kind of mahogany
looking guy kind of mixed you know maybe
could have been
[Music]
he was either kind of black and white or
maybe turkish you know
kind of black and mild i think
you know some uh yeah he was kind of
black and mild you know
he was beans but he was rice you feel me
um
but anyway shout out big anthony over
here off the interstate who hooked me up
with um
you know a good deal on a decent amount
of silver brother
and gold actually i stopped over that
coals in my hometown and i bought a damn
but everybody got golded out in my
family so praise god man i'm hopeful
hopeful that they all liked it and the
kids got a nice piece of neck work
and i got one man you know nothing
nothing crazy but you know sometimes i
like to freaking flex a little
and that's okay man uh
yeah it was a you know i got what else
did i what else is going on man
what else is going on um
oh we got a really cool guest that's
gonna be on later this week
so that's gonna be exciting uh
the holidays were good man i drove home
dude i went to the
slowest starbucks
i want to say it was in hattiesburg
mississippi
and if you haven't been to mississippi
it's very
i mean it is like what is it like man
it definitely it's a little slavey if
you're in some places it's a little like
like you see some of those houses where
you're like that looks a little slavey
um but dude this this freaking starbucks
they had nine employees dude or they had
they had six employees and they had
three people who i think had just bought
shirts who were like maybe in like a
local freaking s bucks
uh you know like a damn cheer team or
something i don't i don't [ __ ] know
you know just give me a venti you know
just
i'd never been in a place where so many
people were working and nothing was
happening
you know and then this one fellow this
big
i mean husk varna this dude who
was built like i mean he had
it he this man was built you know and he
had that body hair and he was also i'll
be honest with you this fella was
probably homoerotic
and and because i would tell you because
he each time he picked the ticket
he would say i'm simeon and i'm the
bad boy that's going to be handling your
beverage
and at first it's cute it's kind of
funny you're like okay okay send me in
out here
you know this mf about to wrangle a damn
you know a chocolaty you know whatever
it is
spanish um
you know custard medium
and this [ __ ] would take forever bro
this [ __ ] will take forever so
anyway i don't even have a story about
that i don't know it's just like if you
work
somewhere then just work there
all you got to do if you it's like p
customer service has gotten
shitty
it's gotten shitty man and maybe it's
just i don't know
maybe anime you know maybe i'm just
complaining but i had to wait 25
minutes for an iced coffee
and in today's society i could
understand if it's
1800 and you got to go down the street
you got to hustle the beans you know
you got to trade your daughters you know
virginity for a sack of good coffee and
you got to come back up you got to grind
it yourself
you know you got to send your lady to
the stream to pick up a batch of h2o
she's gotta come back
you gotta get a fire stick or a hot rock
and beat it in the water you know
i understand if that's the thing
but these bastards have they're
basically sitting at the mission control
of coffee they got machines
they got grinders they got gravity bongs
they got
anything you could have want in there
to put together coffee flavor
or essence and water and get you out the
door
and this big bastard simeon is over
there drawing
[ __ ] uh reefs you know
damn coral wreaths or whatever into the
coffee you know and drawing like a lit
like a
he put one thing he said he told the
lady it was like a like a kiss like a
lips kiss
[ __ ] get the coffees get the coffee
simeon
jesus man i mean literally i stopped
and i just wa i just wanted i just
shouldn't have stopped i should have
left
and that's my choice man that's my
choice when i can't handle it and i stay
um that's my choice
so this year do i have any better
choices i just want to find more
gratitude i want to be more grateful
i should be grateful to live on a planet
where i can pull over
and ask nine people to help me get a
coffee and a half hour later
i can have one i should be grateful
you know but i had a nice time with my
family man i got to see my sisters i got
to see my
beautiful nieces there growing up uh
my sister-in-law is just a real man she
just worked so hard to put together a
nice christmas for
us and and i got to spend time with my
mother man and it was nice
you know it was really nice man we had a
couple moments that i thought were just
just nice moments you know um
and i'm just proud of my mother man you
know i know she listens to this podcast
and i just want to say i'm proud of you
mom
you know i think you are
um
i'm proud of you so i hope you know that
um but
what do we have man for you guys man i
got my love for you i love you
and thank you so much for being a part
of this man we we've been doing podcasts
for over four years now
and that's a lot man and what else
oh i went to jitsu a bunch the past two
weeks
man if you're struggling with some stuff
in your life man get into jiu jitsu man
i'm sure that i'll lose an arm here in
the next week or two
and you know i'm sure my life won't be
the same
i'm sure that i'm gonna you know i'm
gonna have arthritis or something
in a month but it's there's just
something about it
if there's just something about it um
so uh
so thank you guys man for being a part
of my life and
uh and i'm just trying to stay hopeful
and excited about this new year
and to just challenge try and challenge
myself
um you know there's things we can do
where where we could just look at the
negative and uh
and sometimes we do that and that's okay
but it's nice when we can reframe it you
know and we can also look at the good
side of stuff and
i hope that you guys all have the energy
to do that in this coming year
and and i hope that i do too
so gang baby you know i'm saying we can
do this
sometimes we think we can't but i
believe that we can i'm going to turn
the episode over to uh
to nick and sean who are just i'm not
sure how they're going to package in
clips from the year that they really
enjoyed and these are their their
choices um and i'm gonna let you know
also on the way out that
today's episode is brought to you by
athletic greens uh
look man get athletic greens if you want
to feel activated
i mean athletic greens will give you
athletic browns baby i'm telling you
that
and they are just a real composite
of the things that really tickle you you
know it's like damn it's like almost
like
just damn walking through a forest with
your mouth open
and you get to the end of the walk and
you look back and none of the trees have
any leaves on them
and that's because you've been filled up
with that chlorophyll impurities
one of the ways i've taken ownership
over my health in this past last year
is with athletic greens and it is a game
changer
do you take that packet you empty it
into the water that's why
i get one ice cube and i'm at the age
now where i refill my trays
that's people are like how old are you
i'm like i'm at the age where i
reveal my trays
honestly i felt like i was channeling
crystalline right there i felt a little
delia-esque and uh happy new year to
crystalia too i hope that he podcasts
again this year man that's another thing
that i hope
um but one of the ways i've taken
ownership of my health is about taking
athletic greens
and i like it you get that water you get
the athletic greens you get the ice cube
you get it going
and you treat yourself with so many
stressors in life it's difficult to
maintain effective nutritional habits
that's true
i think we've started to feel like we
are almost robots
and we can keep going without taking
care of the equipment
because we see so many other things do
that
um but we are still one of the most
complex and uh
and intricate machines we need to take
care of ourselves one tasty scoop of
athletic greens
contains 75 items minerals and whole
food source ingredients including
multivitamin
mineral probiotic greens superfood brain
food
everything get it all simply visit
athleticgreens.com
t-h-e-o and join health experts athletes
and health conscious go-getters around
the world
and you will also get a free year supply
of vitamin
d that's right again visit
athleticgreens.com
t-h-e-o and get your free year supply of
vitamin d
and five free travel packs today so
that's what you want to get
that's the deal um
man i you know i just don't want to let
y'all go i'm excited
uh i'm hopeful i feel good today
you know and i need i need to recognize
when i do feel good and just say that
and just shout it from the rooftops and
also to recognize this year could be the
year
this year could be there we settle a lot
of the beefs there's a lot of beef out
on the street you know
rv owners and who people that work at
hooters they beefing
um black people and aliens blacks versus
aliens
and that's a new thing but that's i've
asked probably about 19 black people now
and they uh probably 13 of them have
said you know have led
you know have kind of supported some of
that that there's a lot of black alien
beef out there
um what else what else would be you know
people's beefing
other people uh mississippi state and
whatever team they played the other day
you know so hopefully some of this [ __ ]
gets figured out as we head into the new
year
um but happy new year to you and uh
and let's see what the boys have i guess
coming up now we'll have uh maybe a
series of clips
from the year um i'm not sure if i'm
supposed to introduce that or if nick is
gonna put something together but
there's a series of clips from the year
that'll probably play now and uh
and i wish you guys all a beautiful
start to your lives
and uh into your world and it's nice to
have a new beginning
you know especially it's hard right now
for a new year i think to feel kind of
different because we
you know we're kind of locked into our
some of our same patterns but
but i think it can
you know like when you get new bed
sheets or you get your sheets clean that
makes me feel good
so that's what i'm trying to imagine me
just lay just
just getting in there and it's nice and
clean and the bed been made
next cozied up and maybe i reach under
the edge of my bed and get a little
skittle a little something you know
something i hit under there a little
treat
one of them little laffy taffy singles
not the long ones
and um you know i like to fill my mouth
with a snack before i go to bed
but anyway
gang onward to amsterdam
[Music]
and that is a hit
from amsterdam high six is the name of
that band
h-y-s-i-c-s with that regional hit
called made in amsterdam
and that's a strong you could feel the
beat in there you could feel the
undertones and the
different overtones as well amsterdam
the dutch baby
the dutch by far some of the most
aerodynamic people
you'll ever see i mean they're the dutch
are downhill
they're downhill individuals they will
they are in motion imd baby the in
motion dutch
you you don't see a lot of still dutch
name 70 still dutch
nobody can brother okay they're in
motion
doesn't matter they're on a tram they're
on roller skates
uh they're sewing a magic carpet and
riding on it at the same time
the dutch are doing things if you don't
have any missiles
fill your freaking dutch buddy's mouth
up with gun powder
and send him on his way bruh he'll get
the job done
they are movers uh
tell someone in amsterdam to keep a
secret no problem
there they will never stop long enough
to even share what you told them i mean
everywhere you go in amsterdam
they're just
get on on a train on a bike on a boat on
a bird
on a rumor on a breeze ever it's just
[Music]
the dutch are coming and going
i saw a dude pass by on a falcon putting
on skis
and worried he was going to be late uh
for a
regional avalanche they
are on the move where are you going
brother
oh there's a ship you know there's a
unicycle there's a
bicycle doxycycline
rocky johnson i'm catching him he's
headed to heaven
um yeah gotta catch the five train man
to
a canoe to a uber pool
that actually drains into a real pool
and it's a whirlpool
and then i'm meeting joran vander salute
and hopefully
the bermuda triangle will still be open
because we got to be there i can't
believe they let people get high there
okay there's way too many moving parts
it's almost like trying to smoke a blunt
in the middle of a game of
tetris on difficult
i mean i can't being high there just
everywhere there's just
it'd be like being high in a like a in a
conveyor belt factory
bruh nah i found
nah maybe you know catch me
i'll be in the hammock area but
amsterdam they the dutch man i'm telling
you
they're aerodynamic for a reason because
they're on the move
and look if you see if you see a dutch
person this is how you see them
that's a dutch oh what's
oh what's that oh that's a dutch
whoa dang oh man what was it
oh a dodge
what was that oh dang oh
[Music]
what's that oh is that hail nah that's a
batch of dutch son
the dutch are coming and going they're
in motion whoa
somebody just pulled the floor out from
under me nah that's a shift sign that's
plate tectonic dutch
beautiful city beautiful people but you
got to be ready to
move
to move everything's in
you know even the cows there they
running bruh they're not grazing they
don't
you just do you'll see a cow jump over
the moon
dude and do it a couple times that day
everything there
on the go you get a steak at night
there's no meat on it
this cow damn who's this carol lewis
this thing ran right out of his own meat
and the steak be like a damn nugget bruh
like a beef noggy you could throw it up
in the air
and that's nothing bro you know you got
a mouth full of uh
amster steak stay dutch baby
i got a debate for y'all raising canes
or chick-fil-a
raisin 5 gang gang go tigers
gang bro damn dog raisin cane
duh what raisin cane
duh i don't think so bro damn chicka for
lay raisin shame
bro you tell me yeah shoot oh my god
no comparison you tell me you make it
through the atlanta airport without
hitting the chick-fil-a
showing up at the counter seeing the
beautiful [ __ ] girls that work at the
counter admit it they got the best
looking women
that work at the counter you know when i
started eating chicken fillet huh
when i came home from prison flying in
the airport yeah
oh yeah you fly delta do you yeah so i i
i was raised on raise it's no other
chicken finger that was the other first
other chicken
i never ate his ass [ __ ] yeah i still
ain't naked
i still ain't eat that [ __ ] in that
lounge i looked at it i say no
yeah yeah they took my diss the new
razor cane i looked at it
i said hell no cause i was raised on
raising kane like since the first ones
and louise
like i was raised there yeah but dude
chick-fil-a man you get that little
chicken sandwich you open that [ __ ] up
it's in that foil bruh
that thing looking at you like a little
newborn baby got that pickle on it i
hate it before but i just don't like
them saugash pickles all right
i got them soggy ass pickles ice cream
pretty good
okay the [ __ ] nuggets too small one
of those nuggets is three mcdonald's
nuggets now come on
five chicken fillet ass up now i like
chicken fillet
but they ain't messing with no raisin
cane though what's your idea of that
man like truck driver wild bird meat
you know you think it might be going to
his brain a little bit
anyways man thanks i hope you're doing
good
thanks brother back at you man oh i
think if you have a little bit of
stretch but ain't nothing wrong with you
you know there ain't nothing wrong you
wake up in the morning have a couple
eggs and i hit a stretch
you know not everybody gets to have
ostrich so maybe you know you should
you know your brother's lucky to have
that delicacy baby
you know some people they say you can't
eat this and you can't eat that
and i say this watch me okay
unless you're gonna come by my house and
stand by my plate
i might have a little something okay
sometimes i might have me a little cut a
hulk
all right i might have me a little
basket
uh or how i i might have me half a
basket of
seal nuggets
all right y'all don't tell me what i can
have and what i can't
y'all never know i might have a little
bit of canary brittle
before i shut it down for a night
i might have some adolescent uh back
ribs i might bring a nine in the joint
and have a popeye's chicken sandwich
okay
i might have something rare i might have
a little bit of uh
you know i might have some doberman on
brioche
or some carp tarts or some goldfish
filets
with a little bit of reindeer remoulade
drizzle everybody has different desires
so if you got a little bit of stretch
over there
if you ladies drop you know visiting
another man
and dropping off a little bit of that
freaking long neck oh meat to him
well more power to him bro that's family
you know what i hate the most is when my
sister drives past my house
and don't bring me [ __ ]
so thank you for calling man and i hope
everybody out there drops off some
rare meat to somebody that they love he
does have a
different accent so maybe that's you
know that's how they would save money a
lot of french fans dude that one yeah
that guy was from france somebody said
was that guy really from france you
think or was he just saying that yeah it
really
oh that guy from france he had a weird
sense who would just say i'm from france
i don't know
yeah but you're right though maybe he
lied he could lie yeah i'm not saying
he's a liar sorry man
i'll say it he could be i'm sorry i'll
take your pressure off yeah
pretty good and i think the mullet goes
i think we got four different types of
what do you got about back
yeah it's growing out a little bit oh
you got that new york city mullet dude
that business
it's a little too long up top maybe if i
think if i combed it all the way down it
would look like that's
beautiful bruh you look like yeah you
look like a damn raccoon that's going to
prom yeah
it's uh winter time and like wearing
this kind of [ __ ] makes my hair look
like a rat's nest but
it is what it is you know it looks great
man i think you got some beautiful hair
yeah
right we're like four where dude i used
to have like jeff leopard
oh you're it's beautiful hardy you're
doing great
my hat's already back on i'm like all
right anyway what about your what about
your guys
you got that verse i got that i feel
mine is a little bit more like women who
prefer the company than women i feel
like
mine is definitely got that butcher
morgan's is more mullet yours is more i
feel like kind of uh
what is yours earn dude i don't know
well i when i get it trimmed up right
and let it sit down correct this is it's
outgrown i got to get amy to cut it
it's actually bro it's actually a bullet
because i do it straight
i don't know i like that i like that the
best when i do it straight across the
top and let it drop
oh the lord will find you if you keep it
like that people aren't really beautiful
because i can put it back for a casual
set i wouldn't and
i like that that's that's like well
that's real i would do that and drink
out of the bird bath in the front yard
dog
that's full throttle that's like almost
like a british that's like a british
sort of uh
i did this before miley did it i will
say yeah sure
he did no i know i did and i know
miley's seen it
because my name gets dropped all right
and i know she said who's earnest what a
name and looked it up and saw my haircut
and said
they'll never know i took it from him
the majority don't he's trying to get
miley cyrus on a song i'm trying to get
miley cyrus on the phone and figure out
where she figured out that's what i was
gonna hear about that dude
sorry golly i'm passionate earnest damn
[ __ ]
heated huh sorry i drank a suicide on
the way here and i'm
geeked up no you're i mean my aunt sally
dude right now honestly dude 100
and she's badass telling you borrowed
one of my dad's shirts one time to go
swimming in the pool that was not made
of wood
did she smoke virginia bro she smoked a
medium-sized virginia's brush she's a
bigger guy
damn dude i look like aunt sally i mean
she was beautiful too she won seventh
place in a um
beauty contest
but there were thirty entrances there
were thirty thirty so man
there was thirty entrance dude it's top
third almost you know yeah
come on baby dude lips come baby do it
yes sir uh i don't think we even
answered that guy's question yeah yeah
it is favorite what's your favorite
what's your most
you got it what's the most
yeah what's the most exciting one man
damn morgan that's a that's a hard
question
it is really and you shouldn't have to
answer something like that
b don't know nothing a b is like a blind
guy with a damn hatchet
you know he don't know you from adam bro
you know he'll sting his [ __ ]
stepmother if you give him half a dollar
like a b don't give a damn
if you crack open a b there ain't a damn
in that thing
we had a fella out there was a
groundskeeper and a groundskeeper
basically somebody that's homeless but
also
you know it it you know kind of hangs
out in one specific area
and this fella bi they call him he would
uh
he had a glass eye or some type of
textile eye
you know this fella had something happen
you know i'm saying he lost one of them
bad
sight balls and somebody you know hooked
him up with that replica
and he would get b's there were bees
everywhere
b's on every there was bees on
everything bees on every trash can had a
thousand bees on it
and he would take a beat and he would
sting right into his own eye with it
and it would freak the kids out because
we never seen it
and then here you go he's doing it bees
baby
mother nature's freaking pitchforkers
dog
uh and this fellow would just sting his
own eye with him just take him and just
sting right into his
own eye because he had a not a homemade
eye but semi homemade
you know to step up from homemade like
maybe they'd made it in home eq
so he had that you know he had that home
back eye and he would just and if you
didn't know the
new kids didn't know so every time after
lunch he'd get a kid over there and
get his get a live b and sting his own
eye with it the idea of anything that's
like
you know you're turning a straight guy
yeah people
peop that's like a fantasy that people
have but here's the thing
if you do that are they straight right
that's the other thing
like there's a lot of people out there
they're like yeah i [ __ ] your straight
guy it's like
yeah maybe not maybe not right maybe
they weren't being honest with you
yeah you [ __ ] a liar yeah you [ __ ]
someone who's
claiming to be straight but it's like
yeah i know like i've met guys they've
been like yeah i've never been on a date
with a guy before i'm like
that's a lie yeah i'm not the guy that
brings you into homosexuality yeah
you've been here yeah i'm not the
gateway drug the guy yeah i'm not
taylor lautner who's like you're like
let's give it a shot i'm like
you've been down the road a little bit
here
if you're going out with me you've been
down the road you've had some
experiences
you don't go straight to like meth you
know
you hung out in some college party
smoked a little weed then lost your job
and decided you know what i want to
taste glass in my lunch
uh yeah don't know there's there's yeah
i'm not the gateway drug
i'm not like the fun party drug yeah no
so i i think that the people
a lot yeah obviously if it's a legit
straight guy where you're like whoa this
guy's legit straight
i think a lot of people are fibbing
right especially in hollywood i think
they're
lying yeah yeah now do you think there's
also now we talk about drug-induced
homosexuality a lot on this podcast sure
okay and do you believe in that
um that is certain i believe in drug
induced drug addiction
right so i believe that you will do that
i believe that
you will do things to get drugs right
but do you think though that people will
get
[ __ ] up enough that at a certain point
like at 10 o'clock
everybody's having beers and nobody's
gay
at 1am when you know somebody has an
eight ball of coke in them
suddenly two guys are gay out of the
group and you're like oh this is
it might be that or it might be two guys
love coke right
like i like in that tiger king thing
those guys weren't gay
right they went with women right after
that
that was their right yeah he was their
supplier of drugs i see and then after
that they were like yeah i want to [ __ ]
women
so they engaged in gay activities to get
drugs
um i don't know i'm not a doctor is it
possible that if you're doing drugs you
start to be like it's easier to be gay
yeah prop but it's easier to be anything
right when you're on drugs it's easier
to be anything yeah i used to drink i
thought i had money
i didn't have any money but i was drunk
so i thought i was like oh it's easier
to be rich
i'm rich here's money dinner's on me i
was like it's so easy to be rich
i don't have any money then you show bro
i don't actually have money
but when i'm drunk i feel like i have
money yeah so you
act like you have money i say yeah so
yeah so yeah
drug-induced anything could happen
anything could happen yeah
yeah especially the drugs that they have
now you know
like it's like the argument it's like
bath salts it's like is it easier
to fight a pit bull when you're on bath
salts
the answer is yes you know it's like
would that but that person probably
wasn't
a complete stranger to that type of
behavior right that person's probably
choked a [ __ ] uh jack castle before
yeah that purse has probably dropped
kicked a cat or something yeah
and they just got really into like
fighting pits
you know when they had yeah so maybe for
some people it's them taking on a fear
that they didn't know that they had that
might be
it yeah do you think some people view
homosexuality as a fear
yeah sure i think anybody any time you
lose control of your image
you're scared so it when you say you're
a gay person when you say you're a
political like if
somebody says i'm a conservative or i'm
a liberal or i'm a socialist or i'm gay
or i'm uh a vegan all of a sudden you
lose control of your image you lose all
of your individuality because
that group is associated with all kinds
of things some of them are great some of
them aren't
so the minute that people view you as a
member of a group
ah scary and and if people lose their
ability
to like manage their their own image and
then people like oh well you're gay are
you like this
are you going to act like this or
whatever you you know so i think the
fear
is the stigma that's attached to that
group
okay so for a while there's a stigma
attached to homosexuality and and i'm
sure there still is
in many parts of the con and everywhere
so the stigma people fear that
do um are more met do you feel like you
get hit on by more mexican men
or probably on the apps i don't really
answer a lot of the app things but
see that though yeah i got there's i do
well with like mexicans
i don't go out with max against that
white delight i bet they hit on
yeah and that's not i'm not racist but i
just don't ever like i never oh really
yeah no i just you know what it is
mexican would be easy to date kind of
you know especially because
there's a language barrier i've gone out
with spanish guys i don't know actually
like like when you say mexican i think
of like uh like
some guy like a 5'4 just a guy in a
truck
a dude in a truck who doesn't speak
english now i know that
that's a racist thing but i've never
been out
with i think with an official 100
mexican guy right but i've gone out with
guys that were hispanic
but a lot of guys hit on me that are
like from other parts of the world
wow yeah white people don't are not into
it interesting interesting
yeah i think i'm the symbol of i think a
bigger white guy is a symbol of
prosperity
to other races oh i could see that yeah
so i think i think
uh cause you come yeah they're used to
seeing you come to their country to like
get to date
to date and yeah for sex yeah they're
like oh this is the guy
who comes down for sex tourism let's
just get him
now let's just steal his wallet now
this is the guy who who shows up on the
train and looks around a little bit and
nods and yeah
and taps his cane on the ground i go to
the philippines for the food
so let's just rob him now let's just
take his money now
and he doesn't have to buy the flight
dude that's crazy yeah you almost
you look like yeah like i look like a
guy
who looks like a fdr's grandson like a
guy that would go
you know the the eli roth the hostile
that movie i look like a guy who goes to
bratislava and who wants to just saw
people in half
and then just goes back to his bank job
and just sit back on the golf course
just hitting balls
just like yeah i went away there's a
great little spot you can go and just
swap people's limbs off
great tacos yeah good tacos a lot of fun
so i think those people see me and
they're like oh good you know
fat white guy may be prosperous yeah
yeah i could yeah that's totally wild
yeah you seem like the guy who made
like the monopoly that old guy like his
son like kind of one of his sons that
the guy that didn't earn the money but
somehow i have it yeah like i didn't
earn it i didn't come up with the thing
yeah but like i'm orville redenbacher's
great grandson
yeah and we just made bonnie redenbach
lonnie redenbacher i just made my living
popping corn
and i just sit at the local bar and i'm
real free with my opinions
and i've never earned a dollar in my
life i've never earned an honest dollar
in my life
and i'm just living off popcorn money
from like four generations again
oh man yeah it's great it's like being
on your twitter dude yeah
that's not so good that's what i that's
what i look like yeah but again you
can't control your image
right i just look racist yeah i look
like uh you think so
yeah i look like a cop who shot a
toddler oh
yeah you know but you look like the cop
they're like whoa how'd this guy get
like this guy he'd get on the force yeah
how do you how like if you've been on
the force for eight years it's like oh
yeah he's been on the force for eight
years
but if he just got on the force how did
it even happen yeah
how did it even
we'd steal some liquor during the day
and go bury it in the sand and then go
get it back at night like uh
you know like turtles do yeah and so
then we dig it up at night and go drink
it and then we'd meet up with strangers
on the beach
strange women i met this girl that was
in the wicken one time witchcrafter
and me and she wasn't into it she was in
it she was doing it she was literally
walking on the beach in the middle of
the night
no man at age 15 dude and we i don't
know what we did but
we did something man that is always the
creepiest story and especially on the
receiving end
as a kid it's a cool story but when
you're a father
and your kids come back from the beach
saying that [ __ ]
because my son did it in in maui they
came running back in
they're like oh we met some dudes on the
beach i'm like
what the [ __ ] what do they look like
like well you don't hang out with dudes
at the beach
no they were cool dad no they're no they
weren't yeah
no man homeless talking to 15 year old
kids is cool at the beach
that's true man dude when i think back
because when i we had this fella named
richard langenstein and
and the the listeners know this and this
fellow was eventually
convicted or semi-convicted pedophile
and but when i was young he was just
this cool guy
that we went to smoke weed with and
would buy steaks yeah
did you fall asleep a lot huh did you
fall asleep around this guy yeah there's
a couple of half memories that i have
that i don't want to
read all the way through yeah yeah don't
go through i don't want to read the
second half of the book
but he was but at the time we thought it
was so cool that he would
he drove one of my friends to vegas for
the weekend right like pretty sketchy
right there right there a cute religious
brother accused of molesting student
but this was after and you knew him oh
yeah dude
i used to smoke weed with that fella man
he was a teacher at our school man
he was a teacher i introduced him like
half of my friends
so here's what i didn't realize man i
was a freaking like a like a penis mule
for this guy you know what i'm saying
yeah you were bringing him in yeah it is
because i met him at school he was a
substitute teacher
you were like that girl on smallville
allison mack yeah
yeah i was a recruiter she'd be serving
120 years right now thea free gallane
dude
um but anyway but at the time it's so
crazy at the time how i thought oh it's
so cool it's so normal
i'm just i'm lucky we met this cool guy
yeah now when i think about it
okay if at 40 i'm smoking weed with a 15
year old
yeah i'm not doing no man
it would be insane to do that that's it
doesn't even make sense
no it's so wild how from the other side
of the
that's what i'm saying it's so clear
when mike wants
you got to remember i'm taking
responsibility of all my nephews
oh like i've told the their parents i
got it don't worry they're going to be
safe and they come running back into the
into the the house and they're like yo
we met these dudes man there's no coming
duncan took a hit like my oldest cut my
oldest nephew took a hit i'm like
what the [ __ ] are you doing yeah what
are you guys doing
what's going on why would you do that
yeah who are these guys
he just disappeared yeah donkey got his
nails done by some guy
i feel weird if i hang out with gianni
he's only 24. yeah that's a good point
that's eight years does it feel weird
fifteen yeah yeah man
if uh if i get a dm or anything like
that it's always like hey man
uh thank you so much kid yeah tell your
mom and dad i said hi
i swear to god i i don't i
mean hey tell your father
mr coy says thank you
all right man do your homework it's
sketchy now especially dude hell no
i'll ask a girl straight up if they're
going to try to me too me or not yeah
you should
yeah just so i have it in writing
yeah you know yeah that's good like wait
this girl was mean to me and
said she wasn't gonna meet yeah but you
said clearly you weren't
yeah what yeah what's going on here that
corona virus been
covered 19. well i don't know if you
guys know or not but
the primate center that i grew up around
in covington louisiana
and why you know they had us out there
wrangling chimps and when i was probably
i don't even know just
i don't even know how tall i was maybe
titty high on a middle-aged woman
you know top of the titty but you know
uh
they gave that same center where monkeys
escaped in my hometown growing up they
gave them 40 million dollars
to fight this virus
or to try and cure it dude
i'm telling you this man
in my town bro they ain't carrying [ __ ]
man
you know what i'm saying no doubt i'm
not saying but
look they gotta pop eyes four blocks
from the freaking primate center
they ain't nobody's carrying [ __ ] around
there i'm not saying they're not doing a
decent job or this or that or they're
not going to
test and do the tests and stuff but look
if you come down by the chef river
and you expect us
to solve it all save the world
we're not doing that we don't do that
we want the monkeys to have a little fun
we want everybody to flare up a little
we're doing mardi gras we're doing
recipes
we saw we ain't doing all of the
[ __ ]
saving everybody that's not us somebody
has to go
somebody has to go to heaven somebody
has to go to hell we
the we i grew up in this in the stray
animal belt
so you come down and you can pump 200
billion you can put a billion
dollars in 200 billion baby or 1 billion
and look i'm telling you be better off
just buying you a
a dozen a fresh oyster
with a little bit of uh bread pudding
dessert
and calling it a rap son and save your
monkey
and save your money too learn the dirty
behaviors you know the m word first time
i ever heard the n-word
i was at uh i was in i was in first
grade
and these black kids came into our
neighborhood we lived in like a poor
white neighborhood and there was a poor
black neighborhood
like across across across nebraska or
not nebraska
i forget well dude that's pretty far
then if you're
no no no no that was the street name not
the oh right ombre yeah
and so damn this dude did not live by
black people
he said they [ __ ] lived a state away
so they're like wow they're in nebraska
and we were in florida
and it was scary man i gotta be honest
with you it was touch and go at times
yes
definitely i mean we heard stories oh
yeah the rumor mill
i saw a note in a bottle one time in the
river it was crazy
watch out for the blacks
they're coming
that's crazy man oh the n-word somebody
said it
so so these
these black kids lived across this this
main street from us and then they came
into our neighborhood i guess
and stole my football my football had a
duke junior
with a shoelace a tan shoelace as the
strings we just play in the street
and so the string for the shoelace
ripped my dad replaced it with a
with a with a tan shoelace it was very
distinguishable
and a little part we couldn't tie it so
there was a little like part of the
shirt sticking out yeah
so they came into our neighborhood and
they asked if they wanted to play some
football and they had my football
and these two brothers daryl and darren
like yo they're
they must i mean i when i remember this
story i feel like they're 18 17.
they're probably just like 10 11 yeah
and i was six
yeah and they were like yo this is
football and they're like
now this is his football this little
other little black kid
and they're like fight him for it and i
was like i have first grade i was not
fighting anyone i was wearing a
loincloth and knee-high moccasins
oh yeah and so um danny's fighting your
sexuality bro
my dad's like get him some knee pads
he's gonna be sucking dick
so uh so yeah so he's gonna need
knee pads to do it with a [ __ ]
support the union
kind of gay guy puts on knee pads yeah
[ __ ] dick like a man man a backup gay
dude
you mind if i pull my socks up
oh
do you mind if i pull my pants down for
some cushioning on my knees
oh [ __ ] man if i take my shirt off and
just tie it around both of my knees
hey is it cool if i take my shoes off
and put my knees in my insulin
like damn dude i don't even think you
shouldn't even be gay little guy
anyone who does that you're like this
isn't your first time sucking dick you
do this a lot
just sitting on your feet and kneeling
on your fingers oh bro actually
if you had to blow something dude that's
not a bad like i would go through all of
those things before
you you got to like you got to have some
ways to get out of it
i've gotten down on my wife on the side
of the bed with my knees on the on the
um wood floors that's crazy grab a
pillow put them on your knees
yeah the uh but anyway so these black
kids come in the neighborhood and they
they're like fight this kid and i was
like i've never been in a fist fight i
don't want to be in a fist fight
and then daryl and darren looked at me
like like are we gonna have to do this
for you and i was
in my head i was like give him the
[ __ ] ball i don't care my dad already
bought me a new one like
out like and then they got no fight
they get into a fight daryl fights one
of the dudes or darren one of the one of
the younger one
fights a black dude and they're all it's
like it's like five black kids and then
seven white kids or eight white kids
more white kids because our neighborhood
and the dag comes out and the dad starts
chanting
fight fight and we're in a white white
don't win
we all jump in and i am and i and then
he's hitting me it's your ball
[ __ ]
janet janet and here i am just some
first grader
in a loincloth and knee-high moccasins
just
fight fight and then i said then i said
the word in front of my dad and it was
[ __ ] over really oh dad fought him no
no no my dad took me down to their
[ __ ] house
walked me down stood in the [ __ ]
thing and said don't ever talk to my son
don't ever i told my dad everything to
happen they stole my ball this is what
he asked me to say
so we talked to my son and we moved out
of that neighborhood a month later
a month later we were out of that
[ __ ] when i was growing up you knew
not to say the n word if if somebody
beat your ass that's how you knew
you know what i'm saying like that was
the litmus it was like you that's how
you learned about it
it was like oh somebody said it somebody
got their ass beat and then that was it
it's so funny man i never heard it like
i mean i heard it when i was when we
lived in that neighborhood
and then i never heard it in our new
neighborhood never heard it
and then i never i never heard it and i
heard it a little bit in high school but
but it was we had a black friend uh
corey brown
and all the kids that grew up with him
would drop the word but as a like
not not derogatory just as like a joke
if if
if it was the point like in a louis aka
wave it was the punchline of a joke
meaning towards kari or or but very
lighthearted and they were like guys
that he grew up his whole life
and then i heard a lot in college i
heard that [ __ ] well i went to
florida state and we were
segregated it was like fam you and
florida state so i heard it a lot in
college family was more black college
100 yeah and i used to drive the black
chicks
they'd call they always lived in one
dorm it's so funny i ran into this woman
the other day who went
a black chick my age went to florida
state and i said hey did you ever take a
safe escort that's what i
i was i drive them around campus and
like a k-car do you remember a k-car
pull up a k-car can you it was like the
[ __ ] the biggest beater you could
ever have
yeah i think it's called a k-car or a
cue car it's like an old
yeah yeah yeah yeah that was it oh yeah
renault that's a
that's a renault isn't it chrysler k
that was a that was
but it was white and so and then they
would what would happen is
you knew if the black chicks called on a
saturday night because you it was just
taking people to the library is where
you're supposed to go okay
but if the black chicks called on a
saturday night you knew they wanted to
go to famu from florida state
okay and we weren't allowed to drive to
famu but once they got in the car you
had to take them wherever they went so
what would happen is they go
they go we have a pickup at deputy hall
one base 111 i have a pickup at devony
hall
her name's laquisha and you go okay
you'll be like is it how many passengers
are like just one that's what they say
and so you'd pull up
and then she'd like wave to you and you
go hey
and as she waved they'd pile in the
other side of the car and sneak it in
they go
we're going to fam you [ __ ] i loved it
though because i
because i love hip-hop so i would just
talk hip-hop with them the entire time
i learned about wu-tang clan that way i
bought the method man
album through them i learned about uh
suave house
uh mjg and eight ball it was like damn
it was like the funnest for me because i
loved hip-hop oh yeah and so
we would just i'd be like what are you
guys listening to and
i was driving them for like [ __ ] 20
minutes so yeah we're listening to what
there was no player and there was no
player in there sometimes they'd have we
all wearing seat belts and everything no
there'll be so many people
i was back when seat belts were like
people didn't even die back then dude
i see my kids putting on seat belts i'm
like what are you guys knee pads for
blow jobs
what do you got to put your shoes in
your knees and your asics where you blow
a guy huh kids take out your inserts
yeah
you know i took some biscuit out there
to the lake to feed to
some ducks and you know me man if i'm in
a new area i like to get acclimated with
the animals bro i'll pet an
animal you know i'll pick a snail up and
walk three or four feet
and set him down you know save him
[ __ ] five days of travel
that's who i am you know i pet a dog i
whistle at a falcon i'll [ __ ]
you know i go out and feed a duck i see
a duck i feed a duck and i give a duck
bread right
so anyway i'm feeding them next thing
you know i started getting i put
on my instagram story i start getting
dms people angry you can't give them
bread
you can't give them bread you know
they'll die
you know they'll oh this is what they
they said oh
if you give them bread they get too
jacked up on energy
and they will rape each other
look man i'm not doing all of that
i took a half a biscuit and went out
there to treat these animals
to get acclimated to the area
if somebody else if they're doing all it
you know i'm not doing part of
sexual abuse for animals i'm not doing
any of this
if they don't want bread data shouldn't
come eat it that's not on me
people attacking me you're going to hell
bread boy
and then sending me two uh caskets and a
picture of a duck
emojis man
that's mother nature man if there's a
glitch in her pattern they will
she will work it out and these ducks
look like they wanted the bread that's
the thing
you know it's like oh they can't digest
it they will rape each other
well look man i'm not i didn't come to
town to be part of that it's a wild
thing somebody wants to have in there
when they die somebody throw in a little
can of ruffles or somebody put a little
couple star
bursts in there or something okay you
know it's it's not uncommon a
big thing a lot of people will take
cigarettes with them
you know because you take somebody who's
smoking a boy
you know they'll put those they'll put
that you know cigarettes in that shirt
pocket you're gonna want that smoke dude
if you did
if i'm dead bro light me up a damn 100
baby you know what i'm saying i'm
burning a [ __ ] winston
if i'm dead man i ain't milling around
you know i've had you know you know a
lot of people put pictures of themselves
you know
what about a joint somebody sneak a
joint in there sometimes um i'm not
gonna say that that's never happened
because you know when we're when we're
standing back up there and the family
goes up for their final viewing there's
no telling
what they could stick in there you know
i've had i've had some very interesting
stuff you know i had somebody
request to be buried with their shotgun
amen you know so they took their shotgun
with them
you know what about can they now if
somebody requested me bear with an eight
ball
you know and i'm not talking bowling i'm
talking about cocaine baby
can you make can you make do you have to
do that
well the thing about it is since that
would be an illegal drug
you know we wouldn't be required to do
that but you know if somebody
if somebody were to bring that in and
you know stick it up under the foot of
the casket
you know i'm not i don't keep a drug
sniffing dog at the funeral home
so it might just go on through you know
they might just go with them that might
go with them yeah so yeah that's one
thing there's no tsa when you're flying
up to heaven
that's right that's right you're not
gonna be you're not gonna be searched
you know so now uh what's the wildest
thing somebody's put in there somebody
ever put something that's a little too
big in there
you know somebody tried to put a little
chainsaw or a leaf blower or something
if somebody died doing a uh
you know during a dangerous you know
leaf blowing or something you know
you know i've never put i don't think
any power tools in there
but i'd go with a damn sander or
something you know
so what are you going to use that sander
for who knows but
but i'll tell you this if you show up
and you the only dude with a sander
you're going to be
you're going to be steady working that's
right but we're not supposed to work in
the afterlife but i'm sure there's a
couple of opportunities to make a living
you
always want to decide can somebody get
buried with their money if they want to
if they want to bring it in they can get
buried with it have you ever had
somebody that that was their request and
they put it in there
not all their money you know i've i've
had people you know want to get buried
you know
with you know granddaddy always wanted
him kept a
you know a two dollar bill or you know
he always had
change in his pocket you know didn't
want to go anywhere without a little
money
you know i've had that but i've never
had anybody say we're going to put a
million dollars in this casket yeah
because you know then you then you get
to the age-old question
if you put a million dollars in there
let's say you put a million dollars in
there in cash
and then if somebody would take the cash
and write you a check for it you've
still got a million dollars
hmm so so nobody normally puts cash in
there they just
maybe we'll put a check yeah so i guess
if you want to i guess if you wanted to
go with a million dollars we could write
you a check for a million dollars
because
you wouldn't be able to cash it yeah
yeah i'd rather send the check
yeah just in case later you decide dang
i wish i had that cash
yeah yeah have you ever stolen anything
from anybody
no sir no sir that that'd be bad for
business
yeah it'd be bad for businessmen you
know i don't understand why are we going
to space all the time
that we can't handle we we can't handle
[ __ ] here
you know two out of two out of seven
americans can't swim
and we out there getting in the deep end
of the of the galaxy
with no floaties on bro you see what
they send these dudes out there in
this thing like a damn 84 uh chevy
blazer sometimes a bit
the thing they send these dudes out
there
you know and it i just don't understand
what we're doing
it's so lit like i'm not saying it's not
fun to think about what's out there but
i just all of my just sending people to
space
we send two dudes out of florida a
couple spring break addicts every time
down here in florida we blast and two
bad boys out there
it's like come on going to space
the moon that's the thing oh we walked
we had a couple fellas on the moon
dude being on the moon is kind of like
that guy that gets on your
like at a pool party who gets up on the
roof of the house
he's like come on look at me bro
you ain't doing much up there buddy
there ain't nothing up there for you man
and it seems like a cool idea he's
climbing up yeah
yeah yeah then he gets up there it's
like man there's no vending machines
there
there's only the opportunity for real
failure
you know there's only you're gonna end
up in the white section of world star
hip-hop videos daddy
i'm just saying man it's time to get
back to the roots
we gotta focus on our own little space
that's going on here bro bro this chief
calling from texas
what's up chief what up chief
boy and you know this fella probably
huffing on that bag
you don't get the name chief these days
chief used to be a native american
superior term if you're a captain of the
native americans
if you basically this you know the
chris prata joeya if you's a real you
know if you that top dog
in the uh in the feather
in that in that in that feather club
then you would get that name chief
but more recently chief is more of a
okay you know
little gary does a lot of chief in that
hey sucking on that gas bruh puffing
that
that goo goo that herb baby that
that weed huffing that nasty nasty
you know we huffing that [ __ ] you know
mr mcgregor's gunpowder dog i'm talking
about marijuana
i'm talking about that puff puff pow
i'm talking about that poo poo poo poo
to your brain that dope weed onward
i was watching the podcast of the
[ __ ] ladies night one
whatever the [ __ ] that was yeah it was
ladies night brother
onward watching that [ __ ] just now you
said what do you think is going to go
away
in the near future um talking about
people getting their temps taken [ __ ]
like that right we were talking about
people last on
last episode we're talking about people
getting their temperatures taken when
you go to an event
you know you go somewhere and now in the
future they might you know
take your temperature check if a snot
they might
you know touch your kid's little ass or
something see if it's hot
see if you bringing in a little timothy
or whatever with that hot ass
because that you can't do it you can't
do that you're not going to be able to
do that as well
you bring in that up temperature temp
tempeh
it's not going to go over well with
others
let's hear more brother thank you for
the call uh what's going to go away
i think you know you're not from texas
like i am you know but they probably had
10 or 15
mexican restaurants in louisiana what's
going to go away though
is chips and queso and chips and salsa
sun
that [ __ ] is done homie that's not gonna
be on the menu no more son
unless you get it individually it's not
an appetizer number one
you know what i'm saying because what's
everybody doing they're getting the
chips bringing chips to the dip
putting it straight in their mouth going
back to the chips going back to the gift
put it back straight in their mouth
damn you know lean with it rock with it
huh
no you can't sanitize every time you
touch a chip you know what i mean
them chips are just gonna be too salty
after a while so
yeah r.i.p to rrp the queso insults the
gang gang
gang bro man wow i hadn't thought about
that
yeah you can have to each person will
have to bring a couple of their own
chips from home
but yeah you can't have that group you
can't have that that that swimming pool
in the middle of the table
that little cheese [ __ ] strip mall in
the middle of the table and everybody's
just scooping in getting this picking up
a pair of adidas or picking up a pair of
uh
you know motorola or something or get
some speakers or some [ __ ] chinese
food
that chang chop you know
that's going to be interesting man yeah
that could be one thing that could go
away
now you got to bring a couple chips from
home or something you got to write you
know your name on a chip
darren you know little ricky
and a little ricky got four chips you
know and darren got nine chips darren's
big ass got nine chips
and hector hector over there and you
know he
you know chips running his family so he
got 40 chips
come on hector no you got 40 chips bro
shoot the nine pointer papa and i can't
imagine y'all aren't doing
swinging and there's a lot of swinging
out there in the midwest too especially
in missouri
oh do you encounter any of that hey
do you hear any stories of it is there
any no actually
if there's mostly what i see is men that
are single out there picking up
the lot lizards okay you know and
they'll get what they want and then send
them on their way
and then they stop to the next truck you
got to worry about them girls sometimes
because i've been told that they can
actually lay underneath
your trailer and as you're coming out to
say
if you're a man you're standing out
there taking a piss they cut your ankle
they can cut you
cut in the back of the end yeah like on
their hands rub your ass just like
hostile
and that's you got to watch them i've
watched them
at night when i'm just pulled in and
it's two o'clock in the morning
and it's been raining i'll see you know
it's it's actually raining
there's a woman walking around a pair of
shorts and high heels
and she's tapping her door well it's
dark
can't really tell that helps but you see
her you know going from door to door to
door to truck to truck to truck
and then the next thing you know she
disappears for about 20 minutes and then
she's out again
you'll see a light on in the truck
that's the dome then you know they tell
us
ah dome uh-huh uh-huh i know what you're
doing uh-huh
and then she'll come out but i've seen
them walk around
the trucks like they're looking for [ __ ]
right
or maybe they're going to disconnect
something or
pull something you got to watch them
because you don't know what they're
doing
started running into the same fella that
in a car
right up alongside of me just grinning
and waving
you know from his car and i'm like hey
how you doing
and i'm driving on you know next thing i
know he's blown his horn
so i glanced down and he's got his junk
hanging out oh wow okay
his penis huh yeah oh yeah then he backs
off
okay then he comes back up alongside of
me again he's grinning even bigger this
time
oh yeah his pants are down to his knees
this time okay
well i'm sitting here just driving you
know like literally wanting to put my
hand next to my face you know and just
kiss here
because i'll slow down you know for them
to speed up a little bit then they'll go
back and then they'll
keep alongside of me the whole time no
matter what i'm doing oh yeah regardless
of the traffic that's going on around us
it's just you and them in the world
right
slow down i saw this guy five separate
occasions
same stretch of 65 in india indiana
and i named him jerk off jim oh yeah
he's out there huh he painted his
steering wheel
yes he did what color the white
[Music]
that body glaze i bet damn nasty
so you can now you can see his penis now
can you see from the tr
from your oh yeah it's the perfect view
you can see over to the driver's side
i can see everything wow inside of a
vehicle
a four-wheeler so if i'm driving right
and i have my penis
out yes can you and you're in a uh
in a rig yes how can you see my wiener
can you see it
from through the front window no it's
from the side of your side window the
passenger side
you can see from the passengers from
overwhelming me wow
so you're passing me in the fast lane
i'm in the slow lanes two lane highway
like i-65 is through indiana yeah i
could see everything inside of your
vehicle your back seat
front seat driver so if i put my penis
out you could see it i could see
everything that's awesome i could almost
count the hairs
oh wow
almost hell yeah i didn't know y'all had
such good size oh it's a hell of a view
it's the upstairs view from you know
seeing y'all from downstairs
it was like remember when you got one of
those shitty uh those sprint phones
those next tails or whatever
but you could only you could call people
but then you could just
talk to also you could talk to one
person
you could call anybody you wanted but
then you'd be in the middle of a call
like yeah everything's going good
every and then uh your cu your cousin
or somebody fire department whoever the
only other person that had to walkie
your girlfriend she's like we need some
[ __ ] milk
and you'd like honey hold on hold oh
hold on buddy
remember that thing that next tail
we need some [ __ ] milk randle
you're like oh oh [ __ ] oh hold on damian
oh
must be lines must be crossed up
and then you slick sneak uh click over
psalms hey i'm sorry i'll be right there
the uh the uh there's a long line
there ain't no [ __ ] line you're lying
oh sorry man i gotta go bro remember
that [ __ ] next tele [ __ ] was bright
horns dude
it looked like it looked like you they
had it colored because it looked like
you were gonna need to be rescued
like any time you get that bright
colored [ __ ] bro that's [ __ ]
a lot of real poor like sail racks have
like real colorful bright [ __ ]
like oh look at this uh don't you want
this hot orange
and this [ __ ] is hot orange like the
hottest orange you can get is three
dollars
three dollars and four 40 cents for this
7xl uh
and it's like a [ __ ] v-neck
v-neck in the front turtleneck in the
back you're like what
and it's hot hot orange bro and it's
always usually a it's only a black dude
could wear it
let's be honest bro only a black dude
could wear it and they'll look good in
it man
it'll be triple lime that's the color
you'll see on the thing it'll be bright
bright green
the kind of [ __ ] like you can't the guy
like if you drive past it on the
interstate it's obviously the definite
manager of the guy who is doing the
construction
it's that it's like triple lime
and it's size 14 double medium bro
and that [ __ ] got two arms in the front
it's got an arm out the back
for exhaust like heat exhaust this [ __ ]
is
i don't know what we're talking about
bright colors they got bright colored
[ __ ]
and it's mostly it's predominantly a lot
of times for the urban community let's
be honest bro cause they look good in it
you know if white people wear really
bright colored [ __ ] they look like they
need to be rescued
for real talking look black people wear
something mode that's triple lime
oh ernie got that triple lime hitter on
oh whoa
he must be getting married you know
oh he got that triple lime [ __ ]
overcoat
with that double vanilla cumber bun bro
oh he must be
he must be doing a wedding i don't know
what a crepe is but i didn't care once i
saw this lady working there i said all
right
you know i'll lead him until you know
she and i are married if i have to
um they had a girl in there and i saw
her and
you know i made some small talk and it
was
it was awkward because we both had masks
on you know uh
having a mask on
it's kind of like the beginning of like
um shrek or whatever
you know because you don't know how
anybody really
you're not getting the full package
you're just kind of getting that
japanese package of somebody
you know kind of snout up or mid snout
upwards
you know you're kind of getting that um
you know like everybody's kind of a
desert nine
you know when they got that middle
eastern
you know a lot of middle eastern women
they wear the
kind of that word yarmulke whatever it
is that
that muffler you know they wear that
front muffler you can't see them
i was in uh saudi arabia one time at the
airport
and they had a man there and
fat fella i'll be honest with you really
was and i had
if i could think of another word to
describe him i would use it
but i cannot and this one this man was
what you would call a fat
fella and he uh had about five women
with him all
of his wives and they all had on that um
you know just that little kind of
they're all wearing like a what's behind
door number one kind of curtain right on
their face you know you can't see them
all
so that's called that desert nine you
know where that desert eight everybody's
kind of a desert nine when you can only
see the eyes
so she said i don't know what she said
she might have who knows she could have
been calling the police
but i was like oh do you you know have
um maybe we should watch the fight
sometime
and and that was kind of weird because i
didn't
i don't even know kind of how she
responded if she was like yeah or maybe
or
um and then i was like oh do you have a
boyfriend
and that's how i said it too like you
have a boyfriend like i just
got so just i was just strung up
you know just like when you see a rabbit
and he's got one of his legs caught in
the uh
in that wire you know do you have a
boyfriend
and that's how i was verbally you know i
was a verbal
kind of hung rabbit and then she'd like
given me like my plate and
fork and knife that comes with your food
that you order and you just go sit down
at your table and then it comes out
and i was the only person in there so
now i have to sit and i
this is where i really messed up i sat
facing the counter
i sat facing her at the counter and then
i had to sit there and just eat a crepe
which is the loneliest saddest thing you
can eat as a rejected man
it almost feels like one of those
japanese game shows like oh you lost you
eat the crips you know
and so i'm sitting there just eating
this sad
every bite tasted like this girl did not
like me um
but i did it i did it i went in there
i asked her out i didn't get
she didn't i there was no option
and i asked her her name again and then
i
sat and point
blank ate a crepe in front of this woman
very very sad so i went to the park this
morning to get a little bit of heat a
little free heat from the sunshine you
know
a little bit of that vitamin d straight
from the vitamin g-o-d
you feel me i'm talking straight off the
tip of the lower the sky
and just catch that free heat right in
my face and neck
this man heard this old man he's like
char he goes charlie get over here
charlie get over here
and i thought it was too you know
kind of drug-induced or you know
drug-induced homosexual men doing
uh you know splitting up a
you know a gram or a vial of uh
vile of speed but then i look over in
this man
who i'll be honest this man looked like
duty bro
this man looked like just man just real
just just
duty duty and he's yelling at this dog
because the dog smelled something or saw
this and the dog he's over there he's
investigating
you know he might have a little bit of
hound in him or a little bit of uh
investigator gadget or whatever that
guy's name was
remember that show but the the
the dog he's you know he's sniffing on
an orange peel or doing something you
know we're smelling a um
you know a park needle or something or
whatever
and a man's like sharks get over here
just yelling at him and charlie first of
all charlie was way healthier this man
looked like
just first of all looked like somebody
had shaved his whole body with like a
one
or like a one and a half he had a fade
like on his arms shoulders everything
great just
real bristly looking dude kind of guy he
looked like he was
like a pipe cleaner you know what i
remember pipe cleaners
remember in school sometime if you was
one of the weirdo kids and they at the
art class they would give you these pipe
cleaners and say hey do something with
this
and you'd be like what do i do it like
ah we don't know just do something
we hoping you graduate soon because
nobody could stand you you know
and um and yeah this dude
i'm thinking man this dog and then so
then the dog comes over by me
and now i'm kind of pissed because i'm
sitting there trying to do a little bit
of um
legal work or whatever you know writing
stuff and drawing
and this man's charlie leave him alone
so i said dude i said charlie ain't
messing with me man
i said you messing with me by yelling
you're messing with everybody
sir
and [ __ ] it just i don't know man and
the dog went over to him and i just felt
like
i don't know when charlie left dude i
felt like damn bro
charlie don't want to be with that man
and that man treats him bad that's how i
felt dude
so but yeah charlie was like a big dog
and i'll be honest i slept on a piece of
nicorette so
charlie [ __ ] get that hit from daddy
right there
so that guy can kiss my ass bro what i'm
saying is you can't your dog is not a
slave he doesn't work for you
okay you can't you know say this do this
charlie get in the house
no ham hocks charlie nothing for you
you can't be like that to an animal you
got to treat an animal a little bit
kinder i think
yeah it's interesting uh i think people
you you know they look to santa
i think as like a symbol of like hope
and
oh yeah love you know a symbol of magic
if you think about children most
children are takers
they take stuff they want stuff given to
them oh yeah
there are very very few children that
are what i call
giver children they want to give to
other people
they don't want something for themselves
so when i when
that child when i see that child
and we're done with the visit i bring
the parents in
and i said i said and that's when i make
the
the gift of the bell to the child i have
the parent and the child there and i'm
explaining to them what's
what's transpired and i'll tell the
child that every time you ring that bell
i'll be thinking about you oh i love
that yeah
you know there's something special about
just being that uh it's almost to get
like you're like a middle man for um
yeah it's like you're like a middle man
for some of the joy that's out in the
world
right it must feel pretty interesting
sometimes it is it's it's a
it's a lot of responsibility but
it's uh gratefully accepted
responsibility
amen yo this is kenny calling from
portland
i had an idea here i have a playstation
5 that i got from my work
but i would like to offer that to one of
your struggling single moms
so if you have any ladies out there that
are
trying to make your kid happy on the
holiday i have a playstation 5 that i'll
be willing to
donate gang gang gang gang man thank you
kenny that's
man that's where it's at we would love
that it's that time of year man it's
that time of year to
to extend a little if you can you know
the other day i was
i was eating breakfast here and i ended
up paying for
the breakfast there was a couple sitting
outside and when i walked in the guy
said
i said hey and him and his girlfriend
were just visiting in town and so before
i left i just bought my meal bought
their meal
and i'm just saying that because about
two weeks later
i'm across the street eating breakfast
at a different place
and we get up to pay and leave and they
said oh somebody bought your meal
i said dang didn't know who i don't know
who it was
you know some damn scrooge mcduck got
warm-hearted you know he grilled his own
a orders with the lord
he got heated in the heart and somebody
bought me that damn meal
that's caramel roulette and that karma
will really this
this the time of year when karma is out
there karma got on the zoot suit
karma's listening to 21 savages karma
got his nose hairs clipped out he's out
there
this when karma is paying attention so
it's a great time to extend that olive
leaf to somebody
how can i help what can i do and when i
get up in the morning this week what's
been making me feel good
is just saying what can i do what can i
do for somebody that's not me
so anyway what a small little world how
that worked out but thank you kenny
we'll find somewhere we'll find someone
who can use it i think
so hit the hotline if you have some
suggestions and we did we had some calls
that came in man
uh here was the first one that came in
hey this is mike from
philadelphia pennsylvania i just wanted
to maybe nominate my my sister
she works really hard she has two kids
one's eight one's ten
they're real big in the video game so i
thought that would be perfect for them
they're great kids and she's an awesome
mom so thank you mike i didn't mean to
cut you off there man but um
yeah we're gonna we'll connect you with
kenny and um you know that's candyman
that's kenny helping out there those
things are hot commodity bro damn
dude somebody would be dying of cancer
you offering some plasma they say no but
you hit them with that
and they want it bruh let's hit some
other people up hey theo
it's western minneapolis man i have i
got an excellent single mom that uh
she's uh working to get her kid back she
has him about half the year right now
and she's gonna have him over christmas
she has a really great kid who was a big
gamer and
she manages a gas station so she's out
there grinding every day but
amen brother i think we can help out
with that um let me give you a buzz
right now
hello what's up wes bro how you living
man
good who's this this is theo man theovon
the comedian
oh get out of town man what's up
brothers
not much brother's looking for the lord
you know me boy amen
amen yeah i appreciate your call man
it's really nice of you to call just
that you left on the uh hotline
we'd already found somebody already had
called before they got the ps5 but
there's a company that helps us out
sometimes this company called magic mind
and they wanted to offer uh
a ps4 or i think it's a ps4 and a
television maybe i don't know if the
kiddo would
you know if that would be something that
they would like man that would be
amazing dude you have no idea how
awesome you just made my day
dude you made me feel good man i
appreciate it man have a good day dude
and we'll circle up with you bro and
thanks for thinking of somebody else man
awesome peace all right gang i feel my
name is tim
carter i figure let's call in right now
and see what we can do
hello hey what's up man this is theo
vaughn bro uh
i'm calling just about you called a
couple um about the podcast about the
we're talking about the playstation yes
sir my gosh
i wow how are you thank you so much for
calling oh yeah man no worries man thank
you for calling bro
so we gave away the playstation somebody
else had called before you but we wanted
to we want to do something nice
maybe we could just at least set you
guys up with like a gift card or
something maybe to best buy or to some
other place wow theo i just i just don't
know what to say man i just
i wasn't expecting this at all and i
think that's a great idea
and that will be just such a great
christmas this is her first christmas in
portland and that'll oh
that will just be so awesome so awesome
thank you
man thank you bro i don't know these
people but it's just you know it's your
own kindness and your own thinking about
somebody else and
it's funny how one thing like that kind
of spurns the other ones you know
all right gang tim bruh be good man okay
thank you all right cheers brother
hi theo this is susie again um i'm
a single mom i have been looking for
this ps5 everywhere and i'm trying to
get it for my daughter for christmas
she's been doing
really good in school here in michigan
we've been shut down because of the
rhona
mm-hmm i feel you baby that dirty rona
bro that's that long aids baby let me
call you
see what we can do hello hey what's up
who's this
hey it's susie what up
suzy
how are you mara ceo's on the phone
i want to thank you first of all just
for for thinking to somebody else and
just
you know calling and leaving your
voicemail i thought it was really sweet
of you
the problem is we already gave away the
ps5 but i wanted to try and think of
something
else that we could do that you think
would be nice
oh my god i don't even know what to say
how about this
i know it's kind of impersonal but what
if we just gave you like a 500
gift card and you could do something
nice for you guys something that you
wanted to do
i know it's not a ps5 but um
no i appreciate it so much we've we've
been
struggling i mean i try to you know you
know my
attitude is always positive but just to
hear from you
is just wow
well that's sweet of you thanks thank
you for making my day and thanks for the
nice words
theo thank you thank you so much merry
christmas to you your family
like i love your podcast i can't wait to
hear the next one oh my god i don't even
know
wow thank you for the phone call you're
welcome susie
thank you you bet we love you bye-bye
hey pl uh my name is caroline i'm from
gastonia north carolina right outside of
charlotte
my nephew was diagnosed with cancer um
like a year and a half ago but i was
just listening to
your podcast and i heard about the um
the guy
that has the playstation he was wanting
to donate
and um my sister she has two kids
and her oldest son adam he just passed
away in
october from cancer he was 16 and then
she has
a younger son andrew and um
he will be 15. he just lost his brother
and
i know she was trying to find like the
new xbox or the new playstation to give
to him for christmas that would kind of
be special but
well thank you so much for this uh see
if i can get a hold of you
hey caroline hello hey what's up this is
theo i'll call you called uh into the
podcast the other day from the podcast
oh my god yes how are you
[ __ ]
[Music]
oh damn well look just you know what i'm
saying keep your clothes on shorty i
want to get accused of nothing
you know oh my god i was literally just
talking about you
i'm like speechless right now my face is
like pulsating
you might be on drugs i think damn i'm
not
i feel like i am but i'm not okay well
look it sound like
if your damn faces pull satan you might
want to g up a little bit you might want
to
you know you might want to use a skin
softener or something
no i just wanted to say your message was
so sweet i thought it was very nice of
you to call and uh
i think playstations are just all sold
out so we're committed to help find like
a um
xbox do you think the kids would want
that or do you think we should just wait
and
whenever playstations come back he would
prefer an xbox if he got an xbox he
would
poop in his pants well damn y'all's
whole family need to tighten up it
sounds like but uh
we're going through stuff all right
y'all be good all right stay off them
percocets girl you know it
okay i will okay deal deal deal and i
will too
okay okay good okay deal
bye oh man that's great
that's sweet i think we got i think we
got to a good space here
i think we got to a good space
you know these are our lives man these
are our lives
these are our lives and we got to live
them
you know we got to live them
so if you're struggling with some
motivation i i you know i really hope
that you
find it and and just take that next step
take a small step and a few small steps
make a big step
and a few big steps
make a real distance this is our lives
you know and we all have different ways
that we go about fighting
um but uh
but we don't give up you guys be good to
yourselves man
and i'm gonna do the same for me man we
deserve it brother gang
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be
so far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's
[Music]
i'll been and tell you my story